i
saw a sign in in december that said
now we revolt and we was capitalized it
was somebody on the right
that was holding it and it just because
that was of course after you know
biden's won the election
and uh and uh i
just had this ominous feeling going into
the new year of when is it gonna
boomerang back
i did not know it would be so soon so
definitive and on such a
massive scale and one the
of the of the right wingers that i
that i uh interviewed said this is how
he characterized it he said these people
some of them have
you know former military training and
they don't
they're upset they um the way that
you know folks like us are portrayed
constantly
uh across the boards the the fact that
uh
this stuff has gone on as long as it had
on the left without the media really
being honest with it
he said i'm very worried i'm very
worried this is before
you know the capital on january 6 he
said i'm very worried about what what
is going to happen that's somebody who's
considered a moderate and he was called
a capitulator
and so forth we will not capitulate is
sort of the the talking point from
the those on the right so uh i do want
to address
this experience of being in the middle
of all this and
you can tell that i'm still uh hyped up
on it in the sense that i've
not only had was there to live
have the lived experience but then i
have to go and i have to research and
stay up all night looking at all the
stuff that i've missed and that that i
didn't see
that there were people we were on the
west side of the capitol there were
people who came in from the east side of
the capitol even
you know keeping track of the fatalities
and what what uh
the processes that you know the new york
times wrote a piece in which they really
lay out
the different uh the timeline and and
the geography of it because people are
again i have to say this is a
five-hour event there were highs and
lows of course there were times where
these folks were
crash clashing with the cops and there
were times where
where i'm sure it would have been
you know just turn on the good cop thing
and try to just
and there were probably times of
submission where you have tens of
thousands of people who have breached
the capital of the united states of
america are you going to
you know after people have died one
a woman is shot another woman we know uh
it was you know suffocated in trample
and then two others died possibly heart
attack and and
uh other other causes so so you know
people are dying
at what point is that photo that you
take to make your
your social justice point where does
that lie in that five hour timeline
right that's significant and this is the
other thing
that that you know i came out a little
heated about
is that there's a picture on cnn it was
a cnn
photo and they ran an article saying
comparing police reaction and look this
is the first
12 hours you're gonna make you don't
know you just don't know
yet and you're already putting this
stuff out there
that's gonna make its way all the way to
the president-elect of the united states
and you don't know do you know why
because you weren't there you're
somebody that's
that's quarantined writing and
interpreting the twitter feeds where do
your twitter feeds come from
do you follow activists you probably do
and you're probably getting the viral
clips that are cherry-picked that come
out and they say look you know
look this guy was taking a selfie and
you say oh these guys just walked in
and you're making those claims before
the new york the new york times took
their
took a day and then they they put it out
and they gave an accurate
you know you know who the sources are
that are doing real journalism you know
who those are who are jumping on a wave
to get you outraged because they know
that that makes money
that that that that facilitates
engagement from viewers but the the
photo that went viral that i even my mom
sent was this photo outside the lincoln
memorial and you see
all of the the national guard in riot
gear
and in in the the idea is this was the
response to black lives matter
and you know these people just walked in
what date was that photo from it was
from june the second
does anybody remember that on may 29th
the president of the united states was
bunkering himself at the white house
that's the 29th 30th 31st first that's
the fifth
day you're trying to tell me you're the
the what you're selling me from this
image on the fifth day of a national
riot
the fifth day in washington even longer
if you can include
um washington dc to be specific
even longer if you include uh the
national crisis that we're
in you're going to tell me you're going
to take that and you're going to take
this guy getting a selfie at some point
within the five-hour siege that broke
through the capitol
and yes you did have people as i said
saying traitor and oath
breaker and others that were saying
thank you for your service
and you're going to cherry pick those
two and you're going to make this grand
claim
without talking and you can do it that's
fine if you're an activist
but you're going to do it without
talking to the people that were on the
ground
any of them doing any journalistic
taking any steps to be a journalist and
talk to people that were there and
find out what were the attitudes who was
there
how many how many times did they have to
breach the police
what was the structure why were they
going climb monkey bars up
up scaffolding there's there's a huge
this is a huge cataclysmic event
and people by the time i got to my car
friends
i went to social media and they were
they were sharing those exact points
they were saying
and it was lined up it was just and
you have to i trace it to the 2pm hour
and this is a very specific tweet that i
saw
from a reporter who actually inspired me
to come up to portland
over the summer robert evans he has been
embedded
with the leftists and can and he markets
himself
as a watchdog for far-right extremism
he is business insider uh had an artic
article of his immediately critical of
police and this is why
this all happened but he tweets at 2 15
uh something that would be proven wrong
and i just want to read this because
because if you have and i don't want to
single
out mr evans uh he's somebody who i
invited full disclosure onto my podcast
because i i pitched to him we should
talk about the difference
of in-bed reporting domestically and
he's also been
abroad i want to say to like syria and
other places
when you're embedded abroad and
domestically what issues does this bring
up
and i wanted to have a real conversation
with him and
so i did approach him uh previously but
he tweets
at 2 15 blm supporters would have been
shot with live ammo the instant they
broke through the barricades
that's 2 15 p.m we're an hour and
uh you know a half roughly into this
thing
news isn't out yet that somebody was
shot and killed in the neck
so already the activist outrage is
churning
before the story is even a quarter on
its way
in real time the activist the keyboard
warriors
get this out there now now that's an
account with 187
000 followers many of them young and
that makes its way and i'm not saying
it's just one person i'm saying there
could be parallel thinkers that are
seizing upon the same talking point
pretty soon you have cnn
your van jones is is echoing this and
saying young people feel this way
that if it were black people it would be
this response so we're making
no effort culturally to find out what
happened
who was there what they wanted they're
just
again it's heresy if you if you do
anything beyond
issuing the brand a fascist that's
it that's all that the that this
web journalistic culture
is willing to accept and i don't even i
use the word journalistic
in that term excuse me because because
how is this happening
and in full disclosure i gave him a
terse reply i said one you know a woman
was just shot and we
we got into it uh a little because i i
am critical of this tribalism and uh i
pointed out
something that would be later confirmed
by
the extremist uh that
uh the guy his name was mark this is the
thing these people give their names
they're not hiding behind masks
they're saying we're here for the
revolution and my name is mark is and
this is
the federalist who uh self-described
federalist who has neo-nazi
uh a spouse's neo-nazi beliefs that's
you know uh that's the best that i could
uh describe him
uh he uh he self-des
self-described extremist in there i'm
sure there were others like them
him that were pro coup now uh
so anyways uh they were there
you know i'm not disputing that that you
had those people there
but that the dialogue became
about race so quickly by keyboard
activism and it makes its way to
younger people that are working for
these
big media companies that know social
just like when i worked for that
that company that had all the seed money
they were trying to get young people to
figure out well what what can be shared
and it's this tribal outrage stuff so i
saw this
develop in real time on twitter
the first place i saw this this
connection made was ibrahmex kendi
tweeted that uh
i i hesitate to say exactly what he
tweeted because i won't get it perfectly
and
obviously there's a hazard in that but
the point was
effectively we all know what would have
happened if this had been
black people and my immediate thought
was
in 2021 i actually have no idea how it
would compare
right i i have seen so many instances
where the simple fact that uh you know
black lives matter is being used as a
banner
uh provides an amazing level of
protection
from any police enforcement of the most
obvious and important
laws so anyway my sense was
that this was the creation of a false
fact right the fact that we have been
uh induced to accept is that the
uh the breach of the capital looked very
different because the people who were
engaged in it were overwhelmingly
white and the fact is even if that were
true we don't know it to be true
in 2021 there's every reason to suspect
it's not true because we have seen
a very different uh set of reactions
having everything to do with race and a
sensitivity
to race that has allowed for all kinds
of
lawlessness and violence and destruction
so
you know who knows but your point about
um if if you're a verificationist
right if you're not an honest broker and
you want to sell that story
and you can look through months and
months and months of
riots and find places where the police
reacted
arguably aggressively although to be
honest it wasn't
many of those but over the course of
many months you will have those
instances and you want to compare it
to this you know did you say five hour
siege at the capitol right a you can't
compare the two because one is happening
in the aftermath
of the other and so therefore whatever
happened in the earlier phase
has some in uh has some impact
potentially
but if you were going to try to do an
honest comparison you would compare the
first 12 hours
right and you know even then you
couldn't
do it because that which is being
attacked is different an attack on the
capital is different than
an attack on the federal building in
portland
um so in any case the idea that
you don't it's not that they're failing
to do journalism they're trying to avoid
doing journalism
right what they want to do is they want
to advance a story that explains why
they are going to react in the way they
are to this right they need a story
that's clean and so if they have to
manufacture it from whole cloth
by saying oh there's an alternative
universe in which the opposite happened
and there was a massacre why was there a
massacre
because the people who were storming the
capital weren't white
right well you just made that up right
that didn't happen what's more
you know as you point out you do have uh
the police shooting a white person
inside
the capitol which suggests that
you know whatever the story is it's
complex and it's
not a slam dunk that this was uh a
uh timid response i think there is a
legitimate question
as to why the capitol police
were not better prepared and why
there was not backup given the
possibility that something like this
would happen where was the national
guard
right i do think you know in light of
where we are and
all of the energy and heat surrounding
the election
and the counting of votes and the
certifying of
the election results that uh
it would have been wise to you know
spend what would presumably be a
relatively small number of million
dollars to prevent this from occurring
by having
uh the capacity to resist
anything that could be brought to bear i
do wonder why that didn't happen
but nonetheless the idea that there's
some clear story and that we all know
enough about the way things
function to know that if the skin color
of people who had
breached the capital had been different
that the outcome would have been
the inverse whatever that means that's
just nonsense and
it did develop online as you watched
people
who had a decidedly partisan perspective
attempt to figure
figure out how to formulate what was
happening in real time so that it fit
their world view there was no challenge
to their world view
it just simply matched everything they'd
been telling us all along and something
like this
the stories the most profound stories i
said this about covid
the most profound stories in our life
don't affirm what we already know they
challenge it
they challenge what we think and what
what our perceptions of the world are if
we really
take a deep dive and don't cling to what
our
uh ideology is and i this whole
year has been that for me and let me go
back
to that cnn photo that was juxtaposed of
again day five of of the washington dc
riots and was juxtaposed to somebody
taking a selfie because that narrative
again makes its way from activists to
mainstream media to the president-elect
of the united states who came out
in and echoed the very same um
talking point that a pacific northwest
activist journalist leftist journalist
was was tweeting
at 2 15 p.m by the next day
president-elect is saying it and again
it's not just one person
it was a lot of people because these
people are all interlinked
and they yes they yes and each other and
they say yes
and yes and and all of the activists
uh you know there's a woman who who uh
blogs for or writes articles for teen
vogue
which i mentioned pri that has this big
anarchist section as well
of anarchist literature and uh you know
i follow all these
these people there's a there's there is
a social justice
anti-fascist group that
is extremely quick to spin the narrative
and these younger kids are hooked into
them
so they get these accounts have a
hundred thousand followers
these these younger folks start
um parroting it and so if you tell me if
you work for cnn and this is your bio
i'm not going to name the person
but if this is your bio um
on social i'm part of cnn's
race and equality team this beat speaks
to who
this person is and sees the world um
telling stories of multiculturalism
latinx black indigenous and asian
american communities now that's
something we're all for
and me at least and the intersection of
race with sports gaming
education and more now as i gave that
disclaimer in the middle of it to defend
myself
from the fact that i was naming all you
know
diverse races of which i'm a part a part
of i and of course i want equal
opportunity and better understanding in
this world
if that you know what was it called
again if that
team is the
uh race and equality team which i'm for
sounds great
right and this speaks to your background
and your your experience
if that lens is
first and foremost on the internet with
the young
team of millennial and uh um
generation uh z uh
writers and bloggers if that
is the always going to be the lens i'm
concerned and i would give this
challenge to any young people that are
listening
uh to to me right now because i was in
portland and i did see moments where the
pacifists like myself were at the
bullhorn
and some folks who were in black block
were like willing to listen and willing
to hear
other ideas and if you're part of that
group and
have discussions beyond what's popular
in getting the likes
and getting the retweets on twitter have
discussions
even off twitter for you know
let's let's help us do us all a favor
and have these discussions about
ideas and uh and ask yourself if
everything really needs to be
always through that lens and always
through
the people who are telling you to do
that who you retweet and you look to
if it always has to be that because that
may be that may be somebody's personal
obsession
that may be somebody's identity of
social justice keyboard warrior and
everything about them and not enough
about the people who are on the streets
and the stories
that we need to learn more about in
regards to people who do not think and
like us and see the world the world like
we do
that inhabit the same nation that we do
and
that would be my challenge and my hope
for for
for young folks and and everybody
because i get it from
my friends my again you know my best
friend since i was
uh in high school uh hasn't talked to me
since september
and won't and won't assort with a a
trump
apologist uh again not my
yeah it's not what you are but if you if
he sees you as that
then uh he by his own rules can't talk
to you
well one one quote uh from another
friend
said was what you're working against is
the human brain in some ways
that the way that
we are stubborn and we insist on seeing
things a perfect way and if somebody
challenged that i have another
friend who's who's bless him he's so
reliable that if i say anything about
equal like trying to this is
similar or or that make any comparisons
i get a just a
rant of profanity which uh the best way
the best way to deal with with profane
rants is humor
it just has to it has to be it has to be
we have to be able to laugh again
we can't be so policed in every emotion
that we have
that we can't figure a way to laugh at
the absurdity of
what we have been through collectively
for the last
you know the last 11 months yeah i agree
with you
i think in some sense um
you have to be able to look at anyone
with decency
uh and see their humanity
and then you know those with humanity
and it isn't everyone but it's most of
us
have to embrace nuance which
frankly the one thing you can know about
nuance
is that it's going to deliver you some
things some things about nuance are
going to line up with what you expect
and some things about it are going to go
the other way and if your point is i'll
take the fraction of nuance
that goes my way you're not interested
in nuance so
um we're all going to have to do that
and somehow uh
resist what comes back at us for
engaging in that kind of heresy
i'm going to ask five people
that i emailed before i got to the
capitol
actually the day before i said this is
what i had interviewed
the chairman of the proud boys which
again a huge heresy
back in september and then tried to get
comments
and this is on unblocked podcast which
is part of publicreport.org
i talked to him i got his views and he
told me
he sees his only extreme views view
is that there should be no gun laws
which is interesting that he got himself
arrested with two
cartridges uh there are some
that are speaking of as if that might be
deliberate to challenge gun laws and so
forth but you know i don't want to get
too far into that
he is somebody who i interviewed because
the proud boys have been this
this on the receiving end of a campaign
that you will never be more than white
supremacists not just that
not just that you are that you will
never be more than that there's no
possibility for you to evolve
out of that we've decided that's what
you are because we've
picked these instances but
but we have to ask ourselves how and
this is something i encourage i'm not
going to
volunteer any opinions on the proud boys
i'm going to ask everybody
to start doing their own research and
figure out
how extreme when you listen to
interviews
um if the people who are who are
are these people platform
i can answer that that's no they're
platforming something else and other
other conservative ideals that uh
they say match up with this populist
maga
movement that's why you see them as
security detail in sacramento
like i do um when i have gone to
sacramento and so forth
but but you know again this the heresy
of saying
to people don't take my word for it at
least
look into it yourself because the press
has decided
on cert that certain people are beyond
redemption
and they won't talk about it so if
you're a publication that's decided that
a particular group of people are beyond
redemption
and for some publications and editors in
chief it might
be 70 million plus people i challenge
you
i challenge those five people that i
sent emails to
who were uh members of the raw story
which is the big left
one of the big left tabloids uh the
huffington post
um the daily beast if you're one of
those p
people that work at these institutions
that that decidedly
pursue one narrative i challenge you to
do
other research and buck your own
viewership because we're not going to
get anywhere unless you do
if you keep making money and exploiting
our divisions with this kind of
sensational content that is
in yes you you click up the engagement
you get the likes
and and you profit off that but the
price that we are paying as a society
should trouble you when you try to
uh decompress at the end of the day
from everything that we are taking in
from this
heightened portrayal of anybody who
belongs to the opposite political side
of the spectrum
yeah i i agree and i i i like your
phraseology that they are exploiting our
decisions
for uh financial gain and it's not
only you know it's the risk that they're
putting us to that's the most troubling
because if they keep exploiting it
there will be no putting this nation
back together and the frightening
prospect of its coming apart what that
will do to the west
um who that will leave the world
open to is uh you know the cost is
incalculable
so yes they have a moral obligation to
stop doing that
i would say and it's not inconsistent
with anything you said
but there are irredeemable people
they're not common
and that's the problem is when you take
you know large numbers many millions of
people and you decide
they're irredeemable you're almost
certainly making
a serious error so you know are there
people
in the proud boys who are white
nationalists i have very little doubt
that that's true
but yeah absolutely i don't think it
characterizes them all
and um in any case it is the obligation
of journalists
to to figure out what's true not to
impose what's true
on the story which is what most
journalists are currently doing
my interview with um enrique tario
and i do challenge him on um you know
this is the dialogue that we need to be
having which is why
are is there a proud boys channel that
uh has racist content
and and are you denouncing that he says
he is he says
that they do denounce that and he wants
to see more denunciation
from from the left of our extreme
elements so this was a very
real conversation that we had and one
thing that he said
was i think the lesson is people need to
be heard
that's what they want that that he's
platforming
not ethnonationalism he's platforming
that people want to be heard
that should be a message to all of us
and i know it came from somebody
you've our most of this country is
determined as a
as a irredeemable individual i would
again
challenge you and say do your research
already
mr tario was when i got out of the
capital i stopped by a salvadorian
restaurant and i hadn't eaten
and univision the station that i am a
freelancer for
maybe still i don't know because i
haven't worked for them since i got
furloughed
uh jorge ramos was debating enrique
tario
on national univision news and they were
talking about these issues
and i saw that nice and my jaw dropped
because i
i did not expect a mainstream outlet to
do it and they were speaking in spanish
and sometimes switching to english
and i was watching jorge ramos who we
know
is is very left and anti um
magga and has had his run-ins uh with
the president united states himself
and they're having this debate and i
looked at that and i said yes that's
good i'm proud that i work for that
that organization that they're willing
to take the risk
and have that conversation in you know
somewhat of a cultural bubble
of of spanish speakers uh but those are
the kind we need to take
that lead and have those kind of hard
tough conversations that don't go smooth
and there's a butting of heads and and
you you know your viewers will get mad
at you let your viewers get mad at you
let your viewers be outraged that you
talk to that person
that you platformed them what's the
worst that's going to happen
yep well you know the fact is there's a
large number
of uh that's not a large number in
absolute terms but a significant
quadrant of the podcast landscape
demonstrates that actually although yes
lots of people
won't be interested in hearing things
that violate their core beliefs
there's a lot of other people who are
nothing but interested in hearing
about perspectives that don't match
their priors and so
it's amazing that there's not a
mainstream journalistic outlet
interested in
tapping into that um i think uh that's
gonna have to be a story for another day
but
um the question of why that that
journalistic outlet doesn't
doesn't rise and take advantage of the
obvious hunger
that many of us have for decent
journalism that's a real question
you